bonsoir
voulez vous gagner 100 euros
avec ces cinq mots geneviève de gagner
un peu plus de votre attention je viens
plutôt de mobiliser votre cerveau en
activant ce qu'on appelle le circuit de
récompense en montrant les billets sales
a activé un peu plus je n'aurais pas eu
le même effet si j'avais montré ça ou si
j'avais rien montré du tout
je sais qu'il y en a parmi vous qui ont
vérifié si c'était bien un billet de 100
euros on le voit pas beaucoup cette
ville et d'autres qui sont dit ah bon on
gagne de l'argent maintenant dans l'été
this
j'ai aussi dû créer une petite déception
chez certains et le cerveau n'aime pas
trop être mis en situation d'échec
voici donc un tout petit aperçu de ce
qu'on appelle les processus mentaux
notre façon de faire attention traiter
l'information ces processus que nous
utilisons tous les jours pour apprendre
calculé mémoriser et plein d'autres
choses
j'ai aussi sollicité chez certains
d'entre vous ce qu'on appelle des biais
cognitifs
et ce sont juste des distorsions du
fonctionnement du cerveau qui nous font
parfois agir ou interprétés de manière
complètement irrationnel
mais pour vous parler un peu plus de
tout cela je vous présente pierre et guy
notre cerveau n'a pas beaucoup évolué
depuis cette époque là en terme de
taille je veux dire à peu près mille 400
grammes de graisse qui à la base devait
juste nous aider à se reproduire et à
survivre mais depuis au fur et à mesure
que leurs besoins évoluent et le
fonctionnement du cerveau évoluer aussi
pour arriver à certains des billets que
nous avons tous aujourd'hui
un de ceux que je trouve le plus marrant
et celui qui compare les faits d'avoir
lé fait d'utiliser pierre est capable de
fabriquer ou d'acheter troqué pour la
période tout un arsenal d'armes pour
aller chasser le mammouth alors qu'en
réalité il n'a besoin que d'une lance et
on fait tout sens
personnellement il ya quelques temps
j'ai passé trois semaines à comparer des
cafetières pour au final on achetait une
qui me propose 14 boissons mais dans la
réalité j'en bois qu'une un allongé
allez des fois de temps en temps quand
j'ai du monde à la maison jeudi un
cappuccino wells
rassurez moi je suis pas le seul à faire
ça
maintenant qu'il a passé énormément de
temps et d'argent à fabriquer son
arsenal il va l'emmener même s'il sait
pertinemment qu'il ne va jamais utilisé
toutes les fonctionnalités même si ça va
être encombrant voire pire ça pourrait
même le pénaliser dans certaines
situations cet effet s'appelle l'effet
du coût irrécupérable on ne veut pas
changer d'habitudes ou d'actes quand on
pense y avoir mis énormément d'efforts
et s'était fait là on peut le croiser
tous les jours sur un site d'e commerce
par exemple plus on passe du temps à
construire notre panier moins on a de
chances de l'abandonner et les gens du
marketing connaît ça il y en a dans la
salle aujourd'hui
de retour de chasse pierre et guy vont
vouloir comparer leurs buts en et si
jamais on faisait une irm de la tête de
pierre à ce moment là il ya un peu moins
d'attentes pour les irm à l'époque on
verrait que son circuit de récompense
d'actifs normal il a eu un gros mammouth
mais on verrait qu'il s'active encore
plus quand il voit la taille de celui de
guy
on se compare tout le temps et cet
exemple nous montre que c'est pas
simplement psychologique c'est aussi
physiologique et on aurait pu croire
qu'avec des objets matériels cela se
limiteraient dans notre entourage proche
nos voisins nos amis une famille mais
cela se transpose aussi sur les petits
coeurs rouges et les petits pouces bleus
voyez maintenant l'ampleur du phénomène
des effets ou des billets comme cela il
y en a plein presque 250 qui ont déjà
été identifiés et on continue à en
découvrir et en réalité c'est juste la
solution que notre cerveau à trouver
pour traiter plus rapidement de
l'information et donc économiser son
énergie à la la ces histoires d'économie
d'énergie
donc notre cerveau a évolué depuis des
milliers d'années pour avoir
individuellement mieux plus un cerveau
qui à la base devait juste nous aider à
se reproduire et à survivre qui s'est
transformée à plus encore plus toujours
plus
or au début de l'année un petit rapport
est sorti dix mille pages à peu près le
sixième volet du rapport du giec le
groupement des scientifiques pour le
climat et si je tente de résumer un peu
ce qu'ils disent et restrictions
sobriété en gros du mois et on n'a plus
que trois ans pour le faire
et c'est là on peut se poser la question
est ce cohérent avec le fonctionnement
de notre bon vieux cerveau
entre parenthèses pour ceux qui
connaissent les rapports du giec ça vous
fait pas penser à quelque chose
de grand et de plus et vous finirez tous
en enfer
oui on dirait les messages des religions
du moyen-âge mais bon passons on
reviendra sur les rapports du giec plus
tard
donc entre des scientifiques qui nous
disent qu'il faut - encore - et un
cerveau qui a évolué depuis des milliers
d'années pour avoir plus toujours plus
encore plus est ce cohérent est ce
compatible
moi je dis que oui je veux croire que
oui encore deux autres billets le biais
d' optimisme jeudi que lui et biais de
croyances je veux croire que oui notre
cerveau nous a montré à travers le temps
qu'il a une incroyable capacité
d'adaptation mais retrouvons pierre et
guy pour nous montrer tout ça on est en
2010 et une société d'énergie veut
inciter pierre à réduire sa consommation
en éteignant sa climatisation
pour cela elle lui propose quelques
phrases quelques messages à vous pouvez
gagner jusqu'à 54 dollars par mois b
vous pouvez sauver la planète c'est
pouvait être un bon citoyen d'après vous
quelle est la citation qui a eu le
meilleur résultat
qui parmi vous pensent que senna a levé
la main
away qui pensent que c'est l'abbé à
personne ne veut sauver la planète qui
pensent que c'est là ses
amis donc s'était majoritairement 1 en
réalité c'était des
déjà parce qu'il est toujours une
réponse des en plus était mal cachée
on a juste dit à pierre guy fait mieux
que toi
dans cette expérimentation dans 75% des
situations quand on disait aux clients
vous voisin faisait mieux que vous il
finissait par changer de comportement
ça peut s'apparenter à de la
manipulation mais c'était juste pour
vous montrer que parfois la comparaison
peut être utile mais prenons une
expérimentation que j'aime bien celle du
dictateur
à part son drôle de nom cette expérience
a été réalisé quasiment partout dans le
monde avec toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles et tous les âges
elle nous montre que si on donne une
somme d'argent à pierre pour la
distribuer sans aucune obligation il
peut tout garder pour lui et bien dans
le trois quarts des situations ils le
partagent voire même dans le quart des
situations ils partagent moitié-moitié
une autre expérimentation a montré
qu'avec des bébés de moins de 2 ans il
avait plus de plaisir à partager quelque
chose qui leur appartient plutôt que
quelque chose qu'ils ont trouvé ou qu'on
leur a donné à partager
tout ça pour vous dire qu'on peut
trouver du plaisir autre que dans la
possession le plus avoir mieux il faut
juste changer les imaginaires la façon
dont laquelle on se représente les
choses
et c'est pas en donnant des chiffres
encore plus de chiffres je suis
ingénieur scientifique je comprends ce
besoin d'avoir plus de mesure plus de
données statistiques plus de résultats
ça rassure quelque part et c'est
important
et c'est aussi culturelle une culture
scientifique tractée par les écoles
d'ingénieurs et on voit sûrement de quoi
je parle ici à ça fait 1
notre cerveau comprend les chiffres ou
pas mais ne réagit pas aux chiffres 2°
et 4° ça ne parle pas à tout le monde
j'ai moi même fait une petite
expérimentation par rapport à sa une
société d'énergie française a voulu
communiquer sur 43 % des réductions des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qu'elle a réussi à faire avec ces
nouvelles offres d'électricité verte
et j'ai voulu partager cette information
autour de moi et je les fais de deux
manières différentes
avec un premier groupe où je les fais
tel quel - 43 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre avec un deuxième groupe
ou j'ai dit presque la moitié
je suis sûr que vous avez déjà la
réponse c'est bien dans le deuxième
groupe où j'ai eu le plus de personnes
qui ont cherché à en savoir
pour changer réellement les
comportements
il faut ramener ces problématiques à une
dimension humaine individuelle
s'adressait à la partie émotionnelle du
cerveau et pas simplement en faisant
peur pour reprendre l'image infernal de
tout à l'heure on a vu à travers les
siècles que ça ne marche pas plus pour
nos sociétés ni en parlons que de
sobriété de de restriction de moi notre
cerveau ne s'est pas fonctionné négatif
si je vous dis ne pensais pas à la
carotte
il ya aussi toute la partie conception
de nos succès story la représentation
qu'on a de la réussite ou c'est toujours
celui qui gagne le plus qui a le plus
d'argent quand on voit les résultats
financiers des entreprises quelle que
soit leur taille ou leur secteur
d'activité
quand on voit leurs publicités certaines
entreprises pas tout dans le panier
quand on voit les la majorité des
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux qui
prend le plus le toujours plus et c'est
normal on agrandit fondamentalement dans
des sociétés qui veulent plus encore
plus mais il faut changer
ça peut paraître loin ambitieux une
montagne infranchissable
certains dirais même que c'est naïf
parce que c'est un vrai changement de
société avec plein d'enjeux politiques
et économiques sociaux mais il faut le
faire
d'autres diront que la france n'est que
la partie visible de l'iceberg et comme
le dinh l'ancien ministre tout à l'heure
le gros du problème viendrait plutôt des
pays émergents qui aspireraient avoir un
style de vie un peu alexis à
l'occidentale orienté vers la
surconsommation mais je sais aussi qu'on
a un pays et une culture qui inspire
qu'on cherche à imiter à copier et qu'on
peut aussi inspiré sur ce nouveau style
de vie
d'autres diront qu'il faut plus de moi
c'est tiré par les cheveux
c'est peut-être pour rattraper le retard
mais c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
plus de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre plus de sobriété plus
restrictions mais ça me laisse perplexe
moi je dis qu'il faut aller sur autre
chose quelque chose de nouveau peut-être
pas nouveau parce que j'imagine qu'il ya
déjà des personnes qui ont ce qu'ils ont
pensé se corser mais il faut aller sur
du juste ce qu'il faut avec de nouveaux
imaginaires de juste ce qu'il faut des
success-stories collective autre
nouvelle et ça peut même être
intellectuellement intéressant parce que
le justic il faut vous dire que
continuer à réfléchir à comment on
continue à produire pour répondre aux
besoins mais aussi quelles sont les
limites qu'on se fixe et surtout
comment on fait pour les respecter
je sais que c'est une grosse mécanique
un gros mammouth à bouger mais si ce
soir j'arrive juste à vous pousser à
avoir un petit moment de réflexion avant
quelques décisions pas tout avant un
acte d'achat un déplacement un
comportement vis-à-vis d'autrui pour
réfléchir quelles sont ces ces processus
mentaux qui sont rentrés en jeu quelles
sont ses représentations ces fameux
billets qui rentrent en jeu dans cette
décision j'aurai réussi ma mission en
plus les soldes ont commencé hier
je ne vous demande pas de changer à 100%
je sais qu'on à 20% de nos habitudes
qu'on peut changer et qui peuvent avoir
jusqu'à 80% d'impact encore des chiffres
qu'est ce que vous voulez
chassez le naturel il revient au galop
pour conclure
notre cerveau est une machine
exceptionnelle pour moi la meilleure
arme que nous avons aujourd'hui en notre
possession pour faire face à ces enjeux
climatiques il faut apprendre à
l'utiliser comprendre son fonctionnement
et prendre conscience dès le plus jeune
âge qu'on peut trouver du plaisir
autrement et surtout
utilisé ce cerveau au mieux pour le
bien-être de tous mais surtout pour ceux
propres via lettre merci
[Applaudissements]